have you had stuff uncovered emotionally
in your emotional body
oh absolutely and i've actually worked
with clients
to do that as well i mean that was
something that i
learned because we have such an
emotional connection with food
habits you know or um like things that
they can't seem to really kick
right really comes from an emotional
connection
sometimes it's as you said it can be
like from your ancestral lineage
you know it could be something that had
happened in your soul's journey
from maybe even another a past life
but then i'm doing the healing work to
connect because that sugar craving that
you may have
has nothing to do with your physical
body has absolutely something
that happened when you were like five or
six or seven
that may be carried on from like what
happened with your mom and once we
figure that out then it's no longer an
issue
you have done that many times this
podcast
exists because i love talking to people
and i love going deep the purpose is to
plant seeds of inspiration we enter a
space
of vulnerability and relatability and
what you
realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different
to quote ramdas we're all just walking
each other home
and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense welcome back
today on the show
is serena poon she is a celebrity chef
a certified nutritionist and a reiki
master
so before we got on
i of course always put a lot of thought
and intention into
what i'm going to ask them and
understanding who they are and what
they're really into
and i like had this sort of like block i
wasn't sure exactly what to ask her
and it became clear why and that's
because
the things that she's really at her core
all about
are not necessarily the sort of go-to
things that you would think to ask
someone who's basically a chef
she she is very much into the energetic
realm of existence our own with the
chakras as well as
putting energy into food and the energy
that food is
and like i said she's a reiki master
she's very much into
into the quantum realm of existence into
energy
and we had a super cool conversation
about all these different modalities and
truly to be honest this is a future
conversation because this is really
what's coming
like the yes you're gonna need to have
good food and you're gonna have to
um take care of yourself and work out
and do those kinds of things but the
the the next frontier is in the world of
energetics and i'm thinking i feel like
people are
are getting that um here and there but
that that is what's coming so serena's
ahead of the curve on that and she's
doing
uh incredible things and has incredible
stories that you'll hear about
and she's really here to help people so
i hope that uh you take a lot from this
interview because i sure did
how are you today i'm so good how are
you
thank you so much for having me yeah
you're welcome um
where do you live i'm in santa monica oh
cool that's nice i uh venice not nearby
like venice it's like a little got the
hippie vibe in venice
you're in venice no but i just like that
area when it's right next door
okay yeah yeah it is right next door um
you know it's so funny i have to tell
you so i had just popped down to
your podcast and saw that your latest
guest was was naseem
and you have the ark on yes
i got one for myself my mom my sister
i like told that like a dozen of my
clients get
it i don't i don't know if they all got
one but i'm like you guys should get the
ark so
i'm wearing mine so cool um
well i mean obviously that just like
dumps us right into because
look it's like when i was you know
thinking about what to ask you and it's
like
sometimes when my mind is like confused
or divided i'm like oh it's because
there's two parts
it's like there's not really one part to
ask you about it's really two parts
which is
food but then spirituality i mean i feel
like they both
are they you've sort of merged the two
and they're
but they're you know presumably
they're totally connected but not
necessarily connected um
so definitively or so obviously so
how did you i mean i know how you got
into the food stuff
so how but how did you get into the
spirituality
yeah so it's you know it's such a common
question it's like how did you go from
being a chef
and nutritionist to being a reiki master
and
um really that just that came from my
own personal journey
and i think you know i'm an empath and i
and and
you know i've always had i you know i'm
an intuitive but
not really having an understanding of
what that was
what that meant just feeling things so
deeply always
and um when i was so after
my fourth surgery and i don't know if
that's something you've seen
um in my other interviews or read about
but i
i nearly died after my fourth surgery so
i've had like eight
i i had um mrsa that i contracted after
one of my surgeries and then that became
like a thing
that we couldn't get out of my system so
after my fourth surgery um i
had a massive hematoma i was bleeding
internally
i lost oh i'm sorry that's gizmo um
i lost like two liters of blood nearly
but it was
all internal bleeding it was crazy
um and so after that i
and i that's you know we can dive into
that or talk about that another time but
that was um
i was so lucky really uh to
to recover from that and to have i think
angels
surrounding me and and i had a client
who came and basically grabbed me
picked me up took me to a surgeon that
they knew as they
had in their family and um
and in that process of healing i wasn't
able to use the upper left side of my
body
for months and i didn't know if it was
going to be weeks or months or like how
long
and as a chef i didn't know how
i was going to support myself you know
because i couldn't
i couldn't cook and so i mean i could do
some things with like
my right hand so you know that whole
experience and i think
after having had multiple surgeries and
just the journey that i was on at that
point in my life
i just committed to speaking with a
healer
that i had had kind of like in the
background you know because
therapy didn't was i wasn't really
connecting with therapy i
tried to go to therapy after my dad
after a dad passed away and then our mom
got sick
from cancer so that wasn't really
working for me but
talking to a healer sort of did but then
i wasn't committed
you know i was like 9-1-1 call i would
call my healer
we'd have a session i'd feel better so
after this happened with the surgery i
just felt like
okay so i do my nutrition got that check
like i was really good about my physical
fitness had that in check all this stuff
is still happening not in
like things are still not in alignment
so i committed
to talking to her noel um like at least
every three or four weeks
just to check in just to whether no
matter what if i was having a good day
or a bad day
it just seemed like endless bad days at
that point but still and
after working with her for about eight
months she was like
i want you to come out to santa fe
because she lived in santa fe new mexico
she was the most interesting story
actually she was like
you know she was retired she's in her
60s she was a mom like she did
a teacher done her thing was living in
tennessee
oh no no not yeah tennessee nashville
and she had a calling
and literally was called to
move to santa fe new mexico
left her husband they had maintained a
distant
relationship as a married couple for a
few years her children were
adults she had grandchildren just just
just answered this calling moved to
santa fe didn't know anybody
and she started practicing and just just
her work
you know that she felt called to do and
so
it took me a few months because i was
like okay you're
my master like i i don't know what
you're talking about here to come
because she basically wanted me to come
out as an apprentice and she wanted to
teach
me um what she was doing because she's
like she was 70 at the time and felt
like she was ascending
and felt like she needed to have
like at least one or two apprentices
that she could send her clients to
should one day she ascend
and it took me about four months because
i was like you know that self-worth
that's like who am i
you're my master i can't do what you do
and she finally got me to go out there
and i spent the weekend with her and she
taught me everything
that she did like we channeled we did
all this stuff
like super intense for a weekend and
then i came back and i felt
overwhelmed you know like i don't know
if i'm doing this right
am i doing that like i had my notes and
i had so i decided to take reiki
because i just needed something with
like some more structure
that i could go back and okay there's
like a workbook i'm still applying what
she taught me and what i'm learning but
i just needed something with my
structure
so i started to study reiki and then i
realized
in that process between working with her
and then
studying with her and then studying
reiki that there was that was like the
missing piece
you know and it was almost like i was
already kind of doing it
but not knowing what i was doing and
then now i had
i had more structure and i could really
channel
that energy and really use the energy of
like food and really
kind of like dive into our energy
centers and and figure out how i could
use food
to feed our physical body but then also
our energetic body you know and so that
that's really kind of how it all came
together
and for me it's worked it's worked when
i work with clients
um and in my practice this has been kind
of like the full circle what ties
everything together
when just nutrition isn't working or
just you know dye and exercise isn't
working even though
it just seems like it should this is
what this is what pulls it together
wow wow i love how progressive and like
how we're adding these modalities and
especially the stuff that's like in the
quantum that's unseen
yeah so what was it that you were doing
before
uh that you you know you were kind of
doing some things you said but
this helps sort of complete that and or
maybe give it more clarity or more
direction
um what were those add-ons what were
those additional steps or
processes that you added in after
you learned from her what's her name
her name is noelle noel after noelle
taught you her
her techniques and her and her uh um she
probably got it passed down to her
is she first generation or did the or
did the
the t the healing come from someone else
in her line too
she honestly i don't like she she just
always kind of had a gift i guess and
just you know did it with her
her children and and then just literally
got
hit with like a calling super intense it
was like
you need to move to santa fe and
she did it you know and and you know
when i saw her
she was still you know she's human so
she still had some loneliness
you know she's still because her you
know she lived away from her family but
felt so strong and the message was i
mean it was constantly there she was
always talking to her guides and
counsel as she would call them and this
is just where
what she was what she was supposed to do
so
i think for me it was having a deeper
understanding of like energy
having a deeper understanding and this
is what noel really helped me with
was just constantly clearing my energy
centers clearing my chakras making sure
that they were
spinning moving in the right direction
and and i'd been through
so many surgeries that she said that's
one of the
things where because when you're when
you have certain when you're under
surgery
and you're under anesthesia you are so
wide open like your physical body but
also your energetic body is so
wide open and there's a lot of you know
we call we call
you know when you talk about attachments
i'm sure you're familiar and in
chords for example like energetic wars
you do another person
oh yeah and so there was so much of that
that we had not cleared because until
you're in a space where you
understand that those those cores need
to be removed
that you need to be in your sovereign
space and
so much of that had happened and i had
no idea because
when you're understood you're so
vulnerable and you're so open
and you're also under a lot of
medication which also takes
you it kind of like blocks your
intuition a bit
right and your third eye and so there
was so much clearing
that she had to do in that process in
that eight months and so she would talk
to me
like we would go through like a list of
all the things that she had cleared and
were it like where in my body so were
my energetic center but also were my
physical body
and the the were where there were blocks
that she cleared there was also
physical manifestations of those blocks
and so when she so you can have pains in
different areas of your body
um let's say you know what let's say we
have uh you i'm sure you're probably
familiar with like the seven chakras it
was
more than seven chakras but we focus on
the seven because it's easier
um and let's say like you have your
sacral right your root you're saying
when you feel
ungrounded that's your root chakra um
you might need some
you might need clearing there or just
support and then you can feel more
grounded
with your sacral that's your your
adrenals your reproductive organs your
intimacy your sexuality all of that and
so
when those energy centers are either
imbalanced not in alignment blocked
maybe spinning in the wrong direction
it affects that part of you
physiologically right
and so there were areas in my body that
you know it seemed like conventional
healing traditional healing with
medicine
that physical therapy was not healing
and
working with noel and clearing blocks in
my
energy centers allowed those areas of my
body to have more flow
um and and it and heal and so then i
realized
okay everyone has like a different
vehicle
right and i thought and i realized our
energy centers are in alignment
with our physical organ systems
and so it made so much sense to me to
like if i'm
i'm getting so woo here is that okay oh
i'm i'm i'm
i am literally as woo as you could
imagine so
every word you're saying and i'll pause
and ask for clarification
when i feel like it's it's something
where we'll lose people
okay okay amazing then um so anyway i
just kind of
i felt like you know everything is
energy right when whether or not you're
doing reiki or prana
you know people are always asking me
what's reiki and i say okay reiki is a
japanese technique where you're
channeling you know you're you're almost
like a conduit and you're you're and
you're kind of directing energy
specific area place person thing but
really like we're all energetic beings
so really we all can do that
and there's techniques and there's
styles and there's different names for
it but essentially when you send love
that is the same thing you know when you
think about someone
that you love and you hold them in your
heart you're sending them love is the
same thing
so then i thought about the vibration of
food um and how
whole foods have this powerful energy
like from the earth
and so and so i just thought like
well what if i tried putting energy back
into my body
through food because it just made sense
to me like already with the science of
it
and so and so i was just kind of trying
that on my
you know with my own body as i was in
that recovery process
and then just decided to try it with
with clients as well just to see
like and and just and also adding an
intentionality to it
um and adding in a level of like
mindfulness and gratitude and seeing
how they would receive the food back
into their body because
when i teach people to have like to just
take a moment and walk them through like
a gratitude
process say at the beginning of the day
and then we take that energy
we put it back into the food we put into
our body just doing that
in and of itself takes your body if you
happen to be in a sympathetic state
into a parasympathetic state and then
now your digestive system
is in a space where it can receive
because it's like calm
and relaxed and even that like from a
physiological place
allows your body to process better
digest better
absorb the nutrients better and so it
just
it just kind of all made sense to me
like once i started trying it
and for anyone where they feel like it
might be a little woo
or you know a little rubbish i'm just
like doesn't cost you anything
you don't need me i'll show you how to
do it you do it
and see and see how that feels in your
body as you receive it like
see how the food tastes and in its most
simplistic form
right we talk about we talk about food
as you know and like love is that secret
ingredient
you know we talk about like like the
recipes from our mom or our grandmother
and how we can replicate it to the tea
that that they wrote down but it might
not taste the same
like why is that is even if we use all
the same brands
everything is it really because grandma
left out a secret ingredient
she didn't want us to know about it's
really the energy
that comes through her and it's and it's
powerful
and when we talk about quantum and
resonance if you're going to add that
part in it it kind of makes sense
um but but yeah so
so thanks for letting me go woo on you
i'm gonna keep taking you down that path
because that's so
me um uh i i i love cooking
um i i often say to people to
sort of give some perspective on what i
feel like i'm good at like
i leave out racing because that's what i
used to do and i say if there's two
things i'm good at i could say driving
but instead i say
cooking and working out i'm pretty good
at those two things
um and so i make really simple food but
i always tell people
i because it always tastes really good
i'm like
i think the difference is i love it like
i love making it
i love the food and i don't and i am i
don't even like to throw it away i'm
like a hoarding queen when it comes to
poo because i'm like no no
i put love and care and energy into that
food and like i care about that food and
it's really high quality and there's no
point in throwing that out
and so it's i do believe in that and so
i i mean i think that what it what is
like a technique that someone could do
to start like initiating this practice
maybe like
maybe give us a technique for uh
activating or
checking in with our chakras our seven
chakras
and then perhaps putting energy into
food and some simple things that people
can do at home that are very simple
oh i love it okay so this is this is the
easiest thing
and it's almost going to sound like it's
too simple but this is what i teach
people
and so most people most of us have
some sort of a gratitude practice right
and and if you don't have one that's
okay i would
i would um you know i would recommend
trying one out
so let's say you start off your day
before you get out of bed or maybe
you're journaling
and you're writing down or thinking and
connecting with the things that you love
that you're grateful for
when you're in that process and if
you're thinking about your kids or
your fur babies you know or something
that you love to eat like your favorite
dish you're gonna make tonight because
your best friend is in town whatever it
is
when you're connecting to that i want
you to connect to it
until you feel like almost like a
visceral response like you
feel like a physical response to it
right
and then that's when you're making that
connection that emotional
energetic connection to your physical
body
that's something that's easy for your
body to remember so
you know if you're loving it you're if
you think about the person you love you
literally start to tingle
right you feel warm if you're thinking
about that favorite food that your mom
used to make
um you can smell it you you can smell it
you can taste it you might even like
salivate a little bit
and have all these memories this is so
important then you take this
energy and when you go to your kitchen
whether or not you're just doing your
lemon water at the start of the day or
you're making a smoothie or coffee
whatever it is
i want you to now take that feeling that
you
it's like tangible because you just
connected to it this really
and then you're going to intentionally
direct that energy towards that which
you're now going to put back into your
body
or that you're going to serve to someone
else so let's say you're making
breakfast
you're prepping food it sounds so
simple that it's almost like that
can't possibly it works it's so simple
and you're just redirecting that energy
making that connection it's almost like
it's almost like when you when you talk
to plants
you know we have there's so many studies
and there's that japanese doctor with
the water
and it's that thought it's powerful it's
not tangible but it
is you know and so now you're putting
that energy
back into like a food beverage something
that you're now going to put back into
your physical body
there's lots of studies on that there's
lots of studies the water study
there's the great plant study you'd
speak highly to one plant you hate the
other plants
there's like the rice experiment where
they divided like cooked rice into three
jars
and spoke differently to each jar and
they completely
manifested different mold profiles and
colors
um this is like absolutely a hundred
percent you can anybody can google these
tests but um what's the doctor's emotion
what's his name
true is i think it's um umoto or such as
an m
yeah it's like moto or moto something
like that
look up like water study and you'll
absolutely see
like water being spoken it has different
intentions to it and it shows
um under a microscope yeah the molecules
the molecules
of the water look completely different
so for people listening if they don't
feel like
this is in any way uh
tangible real visual like there are
actual
visual studies of energy into
somewhat live but inanimate objects yeah
they can
you know literally leads to a completely
different conclusion with them so why
would it be different with your food
when you say put the energy into your
food
that still is a little bit of a
confusing directive
so maybe go through the process of how
exactly you do it
so so now you've connected right with
that feeling from
doing your gratitude you know your
gratitude practice gratitude list you
can feel
how it feels when you're super grateful
about something you love it so much
right right you're gonna go downstairs
to your kitchen or maybe you don't have
stairs you're gonna go into your kitchen
and now you're preparing whatever it is
that you're making something to drink a
water
tea you're making your food when you're
when i say
put that energy back into your beverage
or your food
you're doing it with gratitude so you
can literally say
i'm so grateful for this lemon water
because i know it's going to heal and
nourish me
i'm so grateful for this amazing spread
you know of
of food from the farmers market i'm so
grateful i
have a chance to make breakfast for the
person that i love today or
god i love coffee so much thank god for
this cup of coffee
i mean whatever it is that you're doing
it's just taking that moment but
and it could be you're saying thank
thank you it's honestly the easiest
thing to
to do there's a few words that are so
powerful
as we know i am so powerful and thank
you
so powerful so just being able to say
that
to to your food or your beverage as
you're putting it back in or
if you're just prepping that's another
way just to acknowledge
that which is in front of you and in a
way you're just you're honoring that
you're honoring those carrots and
potatoes that you're preparing for
dinner
just putting that energy back in that
way you're
literally sending that energy back into
the food
which changes the resonance you know
of the food which elevates it and then
that goes back into your body and
actually environmentally you're also
elevating
you know the resonance the frequency
around you
as well so so that is something i hope
it's like a little bit more tangible
because now you can have
words and thoughts that are connected to
just like the feeling that you're
directing and putting it back in
so an easy way to uh
to make a reference to it if it's if
it's a little hard
for someone to kind of conceptualize
that is think about someone that you
love it's what you just did in bed
before you got out of bed is you're
going to
just think about how that feels and
think about gosh if that person were
having a bad day
like and i just want to like i wish i
could hug them but i'm not there right
now
and you're thinking about them and that
love and concern that you're sending to
them
because you want them to feel you as
much as you they possibly can even
though you're not there
this that's what you're doing but you're
doing it with
food you know or or bet whatever it is
that you're putting back into your body
and so you're almost like nourishing
that you're sending that nourishing
energy
into it and then back into you and now
there's certain foods that
resonate uh with the different areas of
your body
so you know i'll pick out you know for
example we talked about
uh the root chakra right and so we're
talking about
we're talking about your root and that's
your security that's where people need
to feel
grounded and solid and stable and
when you're not when you're feeling
stressed
or anxious or or out of body or
fearful and you want to feel kind of
like
like strong and powerful again then you
reach for
foods that are that are in alignment
with the root chakra which would be
root vegetables you know or vegetables
that resonate with
that color chakra we was kind of
assigned these colors but that would be
you know the color red so root
vegetables like they're super hard in
minerals and minerals of themselves help
us feel calm so say magnesium for
example
with magnesium and cellulite and
selenium and zinc
these minerals actually help us feel
more grounded you know they help work
with our neurotransmitters
magnesium is a calming mineral so root
vessels are rich
in these type of vitamins and minerals
so from a physiological place
it can actually help you and then just
from like an energetic place
you know they're very connected with
earth energy which is
grounding you know that's why people say
when you want to feel grounded go
outside put your feet in your
toes in the sand or in the grass um
it's it's like it's like you're doing
that but you can do it in your kitchen
yeah there's i mean i've looked into
that too and the colors and
even the notes actually behind me you
can kind of see on both sides i have
uh i have um alchemy bowls
and so i have three yeah oh yeah
there's only six here but there's two
more in my bedroom because i got a high
crown
um so i have all seven and then i i also
got a high crown
um for an eighth and um so i i i'm i'm
like i said
i'm just as woo as you could imagine oh
my goodness i'm so happy to hear that
because oh yeah
i have something to send you but i was
just like oh it's going to be a little
woo maybe it's not woo
well you have an arc on i mean we
started there we started with nasim
haramine which is like the most awesome
scientist
are there other um aspects of
uh sort of the quantum or spiritual or
like the unproven you know kind of stuff
that you're fascinated with it's just
like a pure curiosity and
maybe not necessarily uh exactly part of
your job every day although everything
is always interconnected
well i your everything is interconnected
so i love
i love nasim and everything he talks
about um
dan siegel another person that
absolutely do you know who he is
no oh okay i think siegel man he's in
santa monica
he really he really uses quantum physics
to explain how meditation works and why
it works he's a physicist himself so
he's super cool i'll send you some from
elsinore's name
um and then i saw that you also had
stephen greer on and so
love him too like
i know i'm like we went to we were in
sedona
in november and we are on the hunt for
aliens
so i mean that's another completely
outside of what i do
but have such an interest in uh
what else i work a lot with uh joan
admiral i
know who he is i i find him fascinating
he's a dear friend julianne huff kind of
helped put him on the map with that
crazy like body movements that she was
doing in that video but
um he i mean his work seems fascinating
too that's absolutely working with your
auric energetic field
and he's you know he's manipulating
you through the field yeah he's he's a
dear friend
at now and we also you know and i also
work with him as well like as a client
so we're
both and he's all about the different
dimensions
you know and and i had because a lot of
the trauma to my physical body
you know with all my surgeries and all
these things that happen
i have a tendency to be out of my body
out of my physical body and i will just
super comfortable swim swimming over in
the
upper dimensions um actually i don't
want to talk about this
this that much so it'll be interesting
how this is received but um
yeah so so he's someone that's really
worked with me to help
bring me back and be connected here
where my physical body feels like a safe
space
you know we've done a lot of like
healing and releasing of
the things that have happened to the
physical the physical vessel
um so yeah but that's what he does you
know it's somatic healing and
he works with the different dimensions
and it's almost it's kind of hard to
even explain
no it it i i it is i mean i
it's because some it's sort of like felt
and not it's like hard to put into words
feelings and sort of stuff in that realm
but it leads me to sort of the other
i mean i do that stuff too i have a body
worker i mean i've cried because i've
like
given like sound to like a spot that
wouldn't
go away and you know having this release
so then there's also those other layers
of existence and
look i know that you're a chef and i
know that you've bridged that with
spirituality but again it's all
connected and it's like
you know so many people look to a diet
they look to a workout they look to
certain things and they're trying to fix
it but
like then you get to these other spaces
of reality which are like
which are which is cellular memory
ancestral cellular memory
and or even childhood memory that you
can't remember
that you can't remember things that your
body blocks out because there was too
much pain or trauma
and so it takes sometimes these healers
because we
we try everything that seems easy it's
like a baby right we
you know babies crying so it's like um
feed it and then
maybe change its diaper and then um
maybe it needs
sleep and then maybe it's teething and
like there's all kinds of
you kind of go through a checklist um so
it's not always just obvious what it is
but sometimes there's other things going
on that are just
you so you go through your normal
checklist you're like i'm eating right
i'm working out i'm feeling pretty
relaxed i feel like you've got all these
checklists going on and you're like but
it's not
solving what i'm it's i'm not i'm not
getting the solution i'm looking for and
so
then you get into stuff like with john
working with the body and even reiki
have you had stuff uncovered emotionally
in your emotional body
oh absolutely and i've actually worked
with clients
to do that as well i mean that was
something that i
learned because we have such an
emotional connection with food
right and so often someone's
habits you know or um like things that
they can't seem to really kick
right really comes from an emotional
connection
it can and and i'm so happy we're in
this like space where i can speak so
freely
about my belief system but like
sometimes it's as you said it can be
like from your ancestral lineage you
know it could be something that had
happened in your soul's journey
from maybe even another a past life
and so i've worked with clay and that's
why like with what i do
in my in culinary alchemy like my
practice which i did on myself
it's just you know i'm looking at your
physical body we go through all your
labs and everything
but then i'm doing the healing work to
connect because that sugar craving that
you may have
has nothing to do with your physical
body has absolutely something
that happened when you were like five or
six or seven
that may be carried on from like what
happened with your mom and once we
figure that out then it's no longer
an issue have done that many times
and so for myself working with someone
like
john or other healers to release
you know they're definitely traumas
there that i i wasn't even
because you think you're over something
when let's say
you don't cry about it anymore or like
enough time has passed
you can talk about it without getting
emotional right
you think you're you think you're over
it or you think you i shouldn't say over
it you think you've healed from it
and what i learned in this process of
working with
different healers was that there were
there were circumstances there were
situations that had happened in my life
where i thought i had healed from it
because i kind of just like pushed
pushed past
super strong i'm not gonna let this take
me down
you know and and really i had just
layered on
skin above it you know and so i've
worked with healers and
we've uncovered that and it completely
came out of nowhere where i didn't
even i wasn't expecting that that was
something that was going to come out
um and so that's definitely happened on
on several occasions um with traumas
that have happened
in and there's no other word for it you
know um traumas that it happened as
in in my journey yeah i've noticed even
you know i've noticed from a
physiological standpoint uh
that there'll be a spot or something
that bothers me for some reason for me
it's usually on my
in my back somewhere um is where i i
manifest
uh like where the where things come up
and there'll be something that you know
i call like barking or it's biting or
something that's just kind of like
you know and i can't shake it and i know
that i didn't do anything
particularly particularly to bring it on
there wasn't some weird workout i did or
some move or
something and it's like been there for
weeks now and
and and those are the ones where i just
know that
there is something going on
in my in my energetic body
that's creating a like a a glitch
yeah the glitch in my matrix and
then it's fun it's true every time
that i go in and get work done and have
a release
um you know that spot will then just
disappear
and it's crazy had you have any examples
of that happening
yeah so you've seen happen to other
people
or stories yeah so um
i had uh i have actually so funny i
just got off of a call with a client
earlier today
before i came on with you and
and you know he's been on this journey
but
different issues come up and he's he's
an older gentleman
and um you know he has a lot of
blocks when it comes to his throat
chakra right
which is so interesting because in
his industry you know he's in the
entertainment industry there's a lot of
talking
you know there's a lot of expressionists
by nature of the
of the industry there's a lot of
creative expression
but i think on the back side of it
because he's more like behind behind the
camera behind the scenes
there's a lot of back and forth
creatively where people
have their different opinions and how
things should be expressed in like the
final product in the in the movie
and so you know we're doing a check-in
and he said okay this feels better this
feels better but i've got
this acid reflux really and i have this
lump in my
throat and it feels like i can't swallow
and i said okay well what do you have to
eat right
and we went through what he had to eat
that was pretty much fine
what did you eat and then i was like who
did you have dinner with and then it was
like oh
okay so it was a dinner meeting you know
about a project
that wasn't going the direction that
they wanted to go so i said i think you
have
actually like an energy block there you
know so
can we work on that so did a little
reiki
distally and then i said okay so do me a
favor
and like do you have any blueberries
like maybe you can throw some
blueberries into
into a shake and just have like a big
giant handful of some
of some blueberries and we're gonna do a
little bit energy work
and like that like 30 minutes later he
called me and he's just like i don't
know what you did
this is like weird but you know i it's
if the lump is gone
you know i the love is gone i feel
better and
and so it can be really simple things
like that
or um in my personal journey
because all the surgeries that i had
were in my chest
you know um that's basically where the
mrsa just
found it nestled in a nice little
like hiding space that was kind of hard
to get
to with all the surgeries that i had
i had so many layers of um
so many surgeries so many layers of like
physical trauma you know obviously with
like fascia and scar tissue
and then also emotionally and of course
there's also
pain you know like every single time you
have to cut your
fascia every time you you you sever the
matrix there
physiologically and energetically like
there can be pain especially if it's not
nurtured right and i didn't know
about any of that my first several
surgeries like i didn't even know
how i didn't even have an understanding
of that and
honestly just recently i
was working with a kind of a doctor but
we're doing more holistic
work and we
we were we kind of injected a fluid it's
almost like
like a stem cell type so it's like
exosomes basically
and a combination of like energy
healing to that area plus
this uh fluid it was like
i mean there's much more detail i i
could you know i could take a little bit
of time
to go into all the detail but to to skip
the part now because i'm not open to
sharing
i can't if we had more time but in the
room
in the clinic when we did this
it was palpable like i still get
goosebumps talking about it where
the release like the fluid
released added space between the layers
the fascia and the tissue
finally had a chance to like open up and
then um
and then um and then energetically too
just like directing energy like very
consciously intentionally like just
trying to drive light and healing energy
to that area
it was like and it was so emotional like
the one of the nurses got emotional like
you could feel it in the room
the release of stuck energy
and like the release of like layers of
like trauma and i wasn't i mean i was
like
the nurse got emotional because it was
also so unexpected like we didn't know
it was
kind of experimental what we were doing
um
and it was profound you know and that's
really like
that is science that's the quantum and
energy coming together
and i really feel like this is going to
be the future of health
you know as like we have a better
understanding
i mean that's absolutely what i wanted
to ask you about too was just what's
coming down the pipeline
so we'll get i want to get to that at
the end but i i want to
um first off reiki for people who don't
know
and you say i did reiki you can do reiki
from anywhere i mean you can do reiki
directly over the body or you can be on
the phone
and do reiki because from an energetic
standpoint it doesn't know
time and space so you're connecting
through
i like to imagine the quantum
field as looking like uh the
neurological webbing in your brain of
firing like the neurological
the way it looks like that webbing and
so i imagine that to be sort of like
basically everything we can't see
is that and so it's the connection
um through that field that we can be
anywhere with our energy 100
that's exactly it's such a great way
actually of you explaining it that's
exactly how
how i see it
and so a lot of times when i describe
stories i'm like i gotta close my eyes
i'm sorry i'm really visual
and then i'll go like this but um but
reiki can be done anywhere so
i just think it's important to people
know that because somebody listening
might be hearing this and they might
might think like but i live here and
this might be
i don't know where i'd find that person
and you know in fact i just and
i invested into a company um the name of
the company's wellset
and i had like it was funny i had some
argument and then i was like crying on
the balcony and looking out into the
ocean and i'm like
i just had a good idea for a business
what the hell is that all about but it
was this idea
that there would be some sort of
platform or some sort of
website or something where you could go
and find holistic healers so
reiki astrology um
acupuncture so what i'm curious about
is that we've got to the point where
it's like the spiritual realm the sort
of
the it's kind of like you know i'd say
it's probably more of your final stop it
shouldn't be but it tends to be
so how would you if someone were to come
to you and
want your guidance and help
nutritionally say they had
sort of goals of overall being more
healthy perhaps they want to alter their
blood work numbers whether they be
you know cortisol or cholesterol or
thyroid or
whatever it may be when they wanted to
lose weight and they wanted to get more
healthy
like what would be the protocol that
you'd start with for that so
that's a great question so with i would
say with all people who really want to
work one-on-one
we do a whole or i do like a whole
intake
so i have labs run which i've been doing
forever
um but it's so great because now labs
are so easily available
i mean you used to have to go through
your doctor now there's everything well
there's all these labs that people can
actually order online
and it gives you more insight because
it's not just standard blood work or
what your vitamin d levels are it's your
inflammation markers we can do a full
like adrenal panel i can do so much and
you can know what your micronutrient
levels are
so i have people run several labs to see
what's going on inside your
physiological body
and then i have them do a pretty
extensive intake that gives me
a little bit of an insight of like where
you're at in terms of like
chinese medicine like ayurvedic like
where your disposition
is at and then also i take into account
like what your goals are
and what your lifestyle is because some
people want you know
everything that you listed but they're
sort of like well but i like to have a
glass of wine
like four nights a week because part of
my job i take clients out
for you know meetings or dinners this is
where business deals are made blah blah
blah and they want to factor that in as
well
how we can offset that so it's it's
pretty much like it's an extensive
intake like that and then i also
do like i do an energy intake so
i'll do reiki um you know anywhere
between 30 minutes to an hour depending
on what that person prefers
and i get a sense of like what's going
on inside their energetic body like
where there may be blocks where things
there's some congestion like
where we need to focus some attention
and then
we create like a protocol for you and
that's usually
you know comprehensive in terms of like
the foods that you can choose that you i
want you to choose from like we create
sort of like i don't want to say a meal
plan exactly but
guidance because some people really like
rigid
so that's great that's easy some people
like to be able to free flow
but you know have a list of things that
they can choose from and we just kind of
create this protocol
and more often than not it includes
other modalities that you can do on your
own you know so i love
if you if it's accessible to you i love
like hyperbaric obviously i love led
and you know i love all these other
modalities that i feel are
really complementary um to the
to the protocol depending on what it is
that
um what your goals are so that's usually
what it looks like
you know as sort of like an initial you
know consult with me
um and and and it kind of gives you a
breakdown a guideline
of what to do so with each person it's a
little bit different because your
disposition is different
and where you hold weight maybe be in
your
in your physiological or it may be in
your energetic body
you know you may have a block to solar
plexus and that affects your digestion
your digestive system and that makes
your metabolism slow down and you know
that whole process less efficient
so we might just need to address your
solar plexus
you know and some key foods to eat there
and some key foods to maybe like
substitute out and it's less adding on
30 minutes of exercise and
less you know about calories or
um or intake so which each person is a
little bit different
but you know if i'm working with like a
collective group of people there's like
little check-ins that i ask you to
take inventory of yourself so that you
can figure out
okay is this a congestion in this energy
center where does this align to do i
feel like i'm having a hard time
digesting my food but i'm eating all the
right things and i'm not eating anything
that i have
an intolerance to or an inflammatory
response to
then you kind of know it may be your
energy center right but sometimes you're
eating something
that you do have an inflammatory
response to and you don't know until the
test
so that's why i kind of run you know we
go through it's comprehensive you know
we do kind of all of it
to figure out okay what is it and
there's always a solution
you know we just have to figure out
where to look and then we just help our
bodies do it because
our bodies are designed to heal
and thrive and that's
and i'm sure that you have incredible
results with the people that you work
with because you
you close the loop of of potentiality
with you know cause like you said i'm
sure that in the past it's like
even with yourself you're working
through the standard modalities of
being healthy and then you know once the
spirituality came
in it finally closed that loop um
that's so cool i i probably am going to
sign up to do it by the way because i
love being like a test dummy for myself
and i love it
i like why are we excited i mean me i
like to know the truth about reality i
like to know the truth about what's best
for me
i love when i hear stories about
products that come out and hearing their
authentic origin
so as i've heard you talk about your
product just add water
i i know it's really simple and you just
add water but i love more of the
story about you were making it for
yourself and your clients
so i want to hear more about why what
what were you trying to achieve
that you realized you needed you could
monetize and
make for everyone oh well thank you so
much for asking
about that um yeah just on water it
honestly i was making this because i
have so many clients that um
and i'm sure you can relate they are
just
they they're doing so much you know like
they
are either really peak performer
type of entrepreneurs or a lot of my
clients are
in the entertainment industry and so
whether they're front of the camera or
behind
but especially for the ones that are in
front of the camera sometimes they have
to
they're all over they fly they land
they've got to
look you know and and give off and feel
that
and and and have that like like a game
basically
so you know they don't get a chance to
necessarily go and decompress and
take a shower and do that sometimes they
have to be right on the red carpet
within a short period of time i'm sure
it's something you've probably
experienced
and so and so what was happening was
every time they travel and i wasn't
traveling with them
they'd come back like either bloated or
or sick or they'd gain weight or they
just they'd be carrying a little bit of
weight and inflammation
so i started making this blends for them
like just
in my kitchen like raw organic powder so
i'm like what's the easiest thing
because you can't bring your smoothie
you can't always bring your bread
blender with you can't bring
all this and sometimes you're in places
and those things aren't accessible
and you know i'm always saying whole
foods is the best but if you don't have
it
like have really high quality raw
organic
dehydrated it's your next next best
thing
so i was making this and it was when i
literally just had them in ziploc
like ziploc snack bags and i would just
pile it into
their like bag and i'm like just take
this with you
have one of these like every day just
once a day while you're gone add water
to it just like dump it into a water
bottle or something and come back to me
whole
and so that's what i did um and then i
was with some clients when you're at the
camp
film festival and they were drinking
this stuff
and you're pretty healthy you know you
cook
you cook and when it's really good for
you it's like kind of brown and kind of
green and it's
not the prettiest looking drink if it's
in like a glass right
it looks kind of like sludge and so real
good product like
shout out for myself but that's kind of
how it looks like it's like brown and
green
and they were drinking it and we some of
their friends were also with us
and they were like what is that that
you're drinking because first of all it
looks terrible but
i was with you until like 5 a.m at
you know where hotel do cop and they're
like and i do not look
or feel like you right now so is that
your secret
so it became a thing and i obviously had
some more because i have it for myself
and it's just about
and i say it's everything that you need
in a day now
nutritionally some people are like well
it doesn't have all 17 000 vitamins that
you need to have in it
but it really is everything that you eat
in a day it's got like eight super
greens it's got all these antioxidants
it has probiotics prebiotics
digestive enzymes so when you drink it
you don't feel bloated and it's got
you know really good solid amount of
organic yellow pea protein so it's got
some protein in it as well
it's under 100 calories it's got like
seven grams of carbs it's just
it's what you need to kind of like get
you over
that like little bit of hunger you might
have if you've been running around all
day
some people have what they call a sugar
crash usually you're just dehydrated but
sometimes you might need a little bit of
fuel
this became you know just that water
because these people were like oh we
need this
you know we need it for our we need it
on set we needed it
for our our you know productions we need
it for this and that
so so it became a thing and i had
another company
an owner of a different company there
that was like we have these like health
and beauties
no these beauty and wellness boxes that
are going out in december
can you be in it you know it was like
four or five hundred boxes and i just
said yes
even though like we didn't yet have like
a logo or anything and i
called my packaging you're like i have a
lot of
ziplocks to do with like literally
ziplock bags
i remember calling my sister i'm like so
you know this thing that we've just been
calling like just said water like with
the girls in the gym
just like joking around and we're gonna
need to come with the logo and she's
like
what what are you talking about that's
what happened and we were like
we probably i'll never forget what we're
going through trying to find the right
font
i mean just flowers cross side going
through
hundreds of fonts and just kind of did
it
and it became never mind the trademark
trademarks are a pain in the ass of them
themselves oh and we're finally and
we're registered now like we
own just that water in like the beverage
space
food which is huge and um
you know that's a different story we had
so many people telling us oh don't waste
your money on
pants or trademarks you know you can't
protect your formula you don't even know
if it's going to be a thing and i was
like
i'm still going to do it and i'm so glad
we did because fast forward
you know a couple years later when it's
now even more visible
we have we're registered so it's it's
amazing that we own that but
thank you for asking about that that's
basically how it started
just one of my clients like maintain as
much health and balance as possible
while they're traveling and gone
for them so that they could feel better
and so that they could show up
you know the way they need to show up
and it became a thing and so they're
wonderful because they
they stock their sets with it um you
know
just said water is i don't have children
i have fur babies
come here ella
she's so sweet she's been waiting for
this moment come here
oh my god there's another one too but
she's probably
quite a sweetheart or something but um
we have another one right here too but
she doesn't climb the couches
do you do you cook food for your dogs
yeah they eat home cook
they do a little bit of like um because
they're on special diets so they do a
little bit from like just food for dogs
um but we we primarily just like cook
for them
what do you cook them so gizmo relax
chicken
uh vegetables did you actually do a lot
of vegetables jesse likes rice
we also have to do cauliflower rice and
then
and then he has some heart issues and so
he likes a little bit of beef here and
there as well
but everything is like and even though
we're plant-based you know everything is
like
all organic it's married it's all the
best like it's all what you would eat
yeah just have a dinner party they eat
the same i look at my dog's food and
and and just before i add um there's a
product called balance it
if you make your own dog's food you get
this as a supplement it kind of has more
minerals and
things that dogs need i don't know why
i'd be so much different than a human as
i'm pretty sure i could exist on
turkey sweet potato and green bean for
my whole life but they get that in it
and i'm looking at it
other than that ingredient going this is
a good meal
every time those sweet potatoes come out
of the oven because i roast like six
seven pounds of them
i'm like snacking on them before i dump
them in the mix
so what is your uh what is your diet
uh well i'm plant-based so i am and i
haven't always been
actually um i grew up and i studied
classic french cuisine and i'm chinese
so i definitely didn't grow up
plant-based
but mine is i do i do a lot of
vegetables like i
love vegetables i love my green
vegetables
um i would say most of my diet is either
roasted steamed
i like cooked meals i do do salads but
you know i loved i love cooked and warm
foods i love
soups like so i do a lot of soups um
broth shoots but also puree soups
they're so easy and they feel hearty to
me
uh i'm a huge fan of dips
so like anything that can blend up and
put into a dip so i
obviously do like a lot of um like i
love avocado
it's like we have a relationship i love
avocado in any form
like and then um i do a lot of hummuses
hummus type dips
so and and i do a lot of sprouts now
so i kind of got turned on to sprouts
last year
and i sprout like we sprout
constantly pea sprouts are the best i
love
pea shoots pea shoots are so good
sunflower sprouts are so good
i do broccoli sprouts too so broccoli
sprouts
actually have the highest amount of
sulferophene in them
which is a great like anti you know
cancer
i'm putting that quote in turn that term
in quotes
um but it's something that's so good for
you and it actually
is higher in sprouts than it is in
actual broccoli
so the the the equivalent that you would
need in sprouts and broccoli is a huge
difference but
broccoli sprouts are great it's one of
like the healthiest foods that you can
possibly have
and um yeah we spread everything like
all the legumes we sprout
and all these seeds we sprout everything
and it's so
like the easiest thing to do i never
knew how easy it was until i started
doing it it's the easiest thing to do if
you if do you do that at home or do you
buy it
no i buy it i've i've had gardens in the
past but i've moved so many times and
being in scottsdale it's a tough place
to like have a garden
i know i can grow those because like a
while back i bought this sort of thing i
i
totally took the bait on some instagram
sponsored ad and it was you know like
it was a little tray and then you could
pick the sprouts that you wanted to
grow and within like a week you have
them
and um uh but that was really cool but i
i mean i love growing like back in north
carolina years ago when i lived there i
had a full garden
oh wow but i don't know these they just
grow in the kitchen
in like mason jars so it's like it's so
i'm telling it's like the easiest thing
ever you just like put a couple
tablespoons of it you
you like let it soak in water for six
seven hour eight hours you rinse it out
pour it upside down and you just like
and
it just it just does its own thing you
don't have to do anything to it it
doesn't have to be in the sun
i you mean you just pour it like you
rent you pour out the water from like
let's say you want to do
let's say you wanted to do broccoli
sprouts so what do you do
so whatever sprouts it could be any seed
like you talked about peas sunflower we
spread all of it so just like a mason
jar you know like a glass mason jar
like like like if you have a spaghetti
jar spaghetti yeah right
right and you just make sure it's super
clean and you just put like maybe two
tablespoons of the seeds in there and
you fill it up with you fill it halfway
up with water just so the seeds are
soaking
and you're letting the all the
phthalates kind of release from it so
all the toxins that like plants
naturally
produce right in their own protective
defensive way you just let it soak for
about eight hours
then you pour out the water you rinse it
out so you can get like
it's like canning jars you know there's
like the tomatoes
that comes off so you get the lid that's
got like a sieve
sort of so then you can like pour out
all the water give it a little rinse
and then turn it upside down you can
just lean it against
like the wall of your like on the
counter
um of your kitchen and then like by the
next day
you'll see a little bit of sprouting and
then jar is upside down
yeah but like at an angle you know so it
can like breathe a little bit so you you
turn it upside down but it's kind of
like
it's propped up like well there's like
little stands that you could buy
but you don't need it um you could just
have it like just propped up against
like
you know the kitchen wall you know like
if you're at the
on the counter you can just have it
propped up it's propped up against it so
it's like at an angle you know so
instead of like
upside down it's like this um and then
and then the next day you just give it a
little rinse you rinse it twice a day
put in some water
shake it up rinse it out put it back
prop it up against the wall
like at an angle so that it's not flat
and it has breathing room and about i
don't know three or four days later you
have sprouts
wow so and
because i i love cooked foods too and
maybe somebody else listening loves
cooked food i find
it just makes me feel better i actually
stomach stomachache from
like if i have a smoothie or something
like that i it just doesn't
feel like a digestion must have to do
something some ayurvedic answer to this
um but i and so i like cooked foods but
i know
that i also get a benefit from things
that are alive i call them a lot
you know yeah i say the same cooked
haven't been heated so
it's so great like to have you know
vegan toast with
avocado and sprouts right because then
that's exactly right
something alive to it or um some cooked
ingredients like that you
like you could have whatever it may be
your vegetables your protein and then
top it with sprouts because you're like
there's something alive
yeah yeah
i don't think you'll have a hard time
digesting it because it doesn't you know
i've no problems like digesting sprouts
and yeah
i mean i've been a super nerd i'm really
calm i'm really revealing a lot right
now but i've sprouted in my hotel room
so if i know like i'm going to be
traveling for like
more than a week like like i'll be
trying actually i'm going to be in
paradise valley
right this weekend yeah what yeah
yeah i'm there for um the consumer
health summit
what how do i not know about this i'm a
consumer and i like health
yeah oh my goodness you should come i'll
tell i'll tell michael fishman but you
should come it's like all the
all these you know like nerdy people and
thought leaders and the health and
wellness space it's
and so yeah you come and i'll sprout
anyway so i'll sprout in my hotel so
i'll just bring it like a little mini
jar
and then i'll have my seeds and a ziploc
and then i'll just have it like in my
bathroom and it sprouts and i
i know it sounds so nerdy but if i have
to have hotel food
you know or and sometimes when you're
eating out you can get great places but
sometimes you have to have room service
if i'm in a conference or something and
i get home late and i
i just want to just want to eat a little
something okay so
we're we're to that final question now
where
i knew i wanted to get to but that's
what's coming
and so you know part of it is perhaps
your sort of crystal ball
and also like things that you know are
coming
um and then also sort of incorporating
what you want to come like how do you
what do you see coming through the
pipeline when it comes to
um health and then you know what do you
want to come into the sort of into that
sphere and
then what's the ideal situation in the
end how do we exist
in the most healthy way so i
i really see energy work um
as something that's becoming so much
more mainstream
and people and it's not quite there yet
but people are so
much more open to what it is trying it
out
trying to understand it even if they
come
from a very um science science
background
or even people who kind of need
tangibles so
working with some doctors now i
personally am and just trying to figure
out how we can like quantify
and show show the community who needs
results who
needs numbers um how we're how we're
able to quantify
the healing results that come from
energy right
and also there's so many devices out
there like so many quantum devices that
have been around
since the time of rice and you know
they're just becoming
more and more consumer friendly so i use
a device called the heli and it's like a
wearable
small device that really is very much
the same it's a frequency device
um and it can measure the resonance of
your body and where there may be
different blockages
um and then you can run programs on it
that's preset so it's very consumer
friendly
and i can use it as a practitioner
alongside
you know my energy practice and even my
nutrition practice
i use it as a complementary modality but
you know you can measure like your own
resonance in your body and then like
where you may need
help so i see more and more of these
type of devices becoming more accessible
because this was just fda approved
around this time last year so i think it
was may
that it was fda approved in the u.s for
pain but it does a lot of other things
um but they've been using it in in
europe for
quite a few years now so i see more of
that and i think
that clearly from what i do that that
energy
component with it like really working
with residents and energy and
adding the quantum into what is more
tangible for the average consumer
is going to be the the near future
at least that's really what my hopes are
and
you know and i can't reveal too much
right now but i'm working with a company
where you know we're really trying to
change like
how healthcare is and what gets what
gets
covered you know by the government in
terms of healthcare so right now
say nutrition is not covered by your
insurance you know there's certain
types of modalities even seeing your
chiropractor seeing your acupuncturist
not covered by all insurances and so i
see
a gradual shift towards that as well
that just happened with wellset i think
wellset just
literally got taken on by
um by uh healthcare as uh
oh really like today announced wellset's
been accepted as
as one of five companies to participate
in the 1501 health incubator investment
vehicle created by
first care blue cross blue shield health
works and life bridge health from over
120 competing companies i'm looking
forward to making holistic care mental
health care and preventative health care
more accessible
by increasing wellness coverage with
these incredible insurance companies
over the course of the next year
oh my gosh literally i just
screenshotted that to repost it because
i was like oh my god that's amazing
yeah no look at that that was very quick
manifesting i'm not sure i don't realize
how fast that was but that was
lightning speed that is amazing and i've
done work with wall set as well i've
done
done stuff i'm one of the practitioners
on their platform um and so
and i love the founder i actually met
her at tegan
yeah at um mind body green at revitalife
she's brilliant yeah she's great she
really is and so so
so that's amazing and and again that's
just one
but i see more and more of that
happening because
there's such an awareness and and and
functional
medicine and functional nutrition is
also becoming
much more mainstream um and that's
because of so many of the people that
are out there like a lot of these
um just thought leaders i don't wanna
thought leaders video people who are
very very vocal about
how medicine um and then
and of course nutrition really is is a
uh individualized personalized but also
it's a comprehensive you know
you really have to factor in different
aspects of it it's not straightforward
it's not the pyramid
um so i really see that as our future
that's
that's really uh it's it's very close
you know it's not it's not too far away
your ideal grand
view your utopia your sort of
like dream health scenario
for culture for humans
well really like my dream is just
that everybody really has an
understanding that
that first of all we are incredible
incredible
complicated systems machines just us as
humans you know like
what it takes to run our bodies like we
forget like
how incredibly powerful we are you know
and i and it's get it's so easy to get
distracted by the media
news and headlines and and have those
those um those headlines sort of
disempower us
and so you know i really want i would
love for us to all be in this space to
really
honor our temples and understand how
who we are how we're built what we're
made of and that we
really have this power to heal
to thrive to be even more than
than what how we have been and i would
love that every obviously i would love
for everything to be accessible to
everybody you know we honor
like mother nature because she provides
back to us and so
to be able to have this cycle in the
reverse of what we have right now where
in so many ways we're hurting the planet
and the planet provides
where the planet provides and we give
back to it so that that cycle can
continue in a form of abundance and then
there really is enough for everyone um
it's totally utopian it doesn't mean
that it can't happen
you know i always believe that you know
that energy is put out there and we're
kind of all on the same page
but the power of the collective you know
is is
massive and it's just about kind of
shifting our our mindset
so well it's uh it's down to what what
do we need like one percent i think like
one percent has to shift its
consciousness has to
sort of evolve or ascend to some level
and then
it's a it's a collective rise yeah
there's some study i don't know if it's
like a there's like some monkey study or
something like that
where uh once like uh 10
uh one percent of the monkeys learned
how to do something there was some sort
of
trickle-down effect even without
proximity like a sort of
a shift in existence
and that's all we need and i think it's
possible
along with i'm sure you and kelly and
there's so many of us that
truly believe that it's possible that's
what this show is for
i mean that's what i'm sure the work
that you do is for that's what i do the
show for that's what i
is because it's just little little seeds
of inspiration
to help wake up to um
our untapped potential and sort of
bigness that we you know don't
realize so yeah thank you for the work
that you do
and for um you know
wanting to help people i mean i think
that that's
that's so clear is that uh you
you know you you want to help people be
their best self and
um you've gone through enough
experiences to be able to
you know give people really proper
direction so
thank you thank you no and truly thank
you so much i mean i really
i really really loved our chat today
like i
was so much fun and and um thank you so
much for what you do
you know there's such a magic and a
light that you bring to the world and so
thank you so much um i'm just grateful
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more please click on the subscribe
button